help help help help they hurting me they
Hur me I'm get in the car no help stop
get in
there me get
in a Texas man is now suing the city of
Dallas and multiple of its police
officers after this incident when
authorities wrongfully arrested him
after he was confused with a domestic
violence suspect man I got I got man I
got instead the single father of four
was just on the way to pick up French
toast and bacon for his children's
breakfast you y trouble bro y' don't
even understand y'all in big trouble go
for it I don't care y'all in big trouble
you are under
arrest y'all are in big trouble in a
grid y'all are in big trouble the arrest
dates back to October 16th 2021 when
when a now 27-year-old Sylvester Hayes
was pulled over in
Dallas okay what's your information
that's all that's all damn I'm I'm going
to go get some for my papy something to
eat hey if you're good sir you're
good body camera video shows officers
look over his driver's license and
mistake his name for a wanted DV
suspect yeah according according to a
lawsuit filed by Hayes his first name is
spelled s i l v s r he argues
investigators were searching for another
Sylvester Hayes one who spells his first
name s y l v s t e
r
St I'll explain to
you how give you permission do I know
step out I'll explain everything no sir
tell me
why I didn't give you
permission right now you are being
detained come on and
step come on and step out bro come on
and step
out come on and step out we going to get
taste come on and step
out come on and step out come on and
step out come on and step out come on
and step out step out what y man hold on
hold on bro come on and step
out body camera video shows the moment
First Responders realized Hayes is armed
with a gun they later determined the
weapon was legally registered in his
name on me for
what I
give on on hey
bro this is my guno this is my bro
bro things then become violent as
officers attempt to take Haze into
custody mo
mo
what
resisting stop
resisting my neck got on my
neck got on my
bro doing
bro what am
I what am I for man what am I for if you
let us tell tell you shut up right now
what am I being PID for man y don't even
know y right now bro bro what y
bro
[Applause]
chill
[Music]
chill my hurting meur me manur
me
me me me man bro no I'm not man bro look
at what are yall doing
bro help
help they me me as this continues hay
can be heard screaming while officers
push him into the side of a
car
772 if the other 7s AR work out with us
uh 73 put them out with us put uh 84 out
with us as well and uh start us um
please I don't no get in the car
help get in there y Hur me
get officers then call for leg
restraints to hold haes back help me
help
might me
[Music]
stop st stop stop
stop
noting yourself hey while he's down
search him bro I don't have gun in his
pocket I don't have anything it's on the
floorboard at the front passenger bro I
that is my gun it is in my G you my
stop you're getting this because you're
acting this way this is 100% And I'm not
your
okay my
body BR
stop
ma'am y' don't even understand y'all in
big trouble go for it I don't care y'all
beig trouble you are under
arrest trouble you guys are you good big
trou in big
trouble in big trouble
man I can't even get up
man you
man see
how SC
back Scot
back watch foot
your feet BR what the fuck with multiple
officers responding to this scene these
same moments were caught on several body
camera
recordings
restra un
Lucy hold it off
it isn't my name BR
you stop bro you're getting this because
you're acting this way this is 100% And
I'm not your okay yall hurting me bro
youing my body one
way stop you pressing I know I'm
pressing your pressure point all right
because you're acting stupid BR you stop
I'm a very intelligent black man stop I
don't care all right right now bro all
right let me in the car I get in the car
I get in the car hold I'm telling you I
get in the car I'm telling you right now
I get in the car bro no going to let
you you're hurting me you're hurting me
bro let me
up
St me man not you're the one
acting you bro y don't even understand
y'all a big go for it I don't care yall
a beig you are under arrest additional
recording show Hay's arrest from A New
Perspective stop stop
stop straight straight y hurting me no
we're not you're hurting yourself right
now what are y doing you are hurting
yourself hey while he's down search them
bro I don't have anything bro I don't
have anything bro on the floorboard of
the front passenger bro I that is my gun
it is in my name bro you pressing my
pressure points stop bro you're getting
this because you're acting this way this
is 100% And I'm not your eventually
video shows officers lifting Haze onto
his feet big all right let's get him up
all right go ready 1 2 three up y'all
are in big trouble Man seat in the car I
can't even get up
man
SE scoot back bro
back bro yes
sir
what my
Jesus we need better
legs it's already Lucy got it he going
run
it3
delta3 cam another officer recording
shows the same moments over all right
let's get them up are off ready 1 2 3
upou baby Dam you
black do you see
how Scot
back scoot back
you got the
G pocket and he kept going like this too
he kept
reaching no I did not next Hayes yells
to the officers saying the weapon is
his that's my weapons bro come on you
black man look they do I got I got man I
got
380 Ser number is going to be November
Juliet whiskey
8843 that is my weapon is in my name
that's my weapon is in my name bro y
doing this for no reason man I got bro I
got to go get something to eat for my
kids bro okay I got to go get something
to eat for my kids and that's how they
do me yo video captures hay discussing
the situation with an officer who
arrived late on the scene the officer
mentions the other Sylvester Hayes
confirming there's a warrant out for his
arrest I came in late for everything and
and they handing me so rough sir I ain't
I comped I said what what what what for
I didn't give nobody no attitude or
anything sir I got four kids at ass
waiting on me right now they're hungry
they're hungry I'm trying to go feed
them man and that's it that's I don't
know like they say I fa the fa the
signal at the at the stop the stop sign
I mean I was wrong for that yes so so
that was a reason for contact for the
stop okay yes I understand that and I
was I was going to tell him like what am
I being detained for I don't have any
wars my name is I mean I mean I have
wars maybe for speeding or something
like that but what is your name not for
Family Violence or anything what what is
your name Sylvester Hayes Sylvester
Hayes a name of a champion and they they
they they doing this because they bro my
I don't know if it's cuz my skin it has
nothing to do with the skin look how
they me sir I didn't do anything to
there was a gun right but I wasn't
pulling I told him I had a weapon I told
him this okay I told him this this in my
name okay if they run it it's going to
say Sylvester Hayes okay Mr Hayes so and
I I don't know all the story but there
is a another Sylvester Hayes right so
give me a second right and and that
Sylvester Hayes does have a
warrant then maybe that's I'm the third
man okay so your last name is
hey Sylvester s s s i l b e s t e r okay
and then your date of
birth February
23rd
1996 okay and I'm the
third we we we can handle all this but
when guns or and stuff like that are in
play I didn't pull anything sir no no no
and and I never said you did
with everything come on man with
everything that's going on now why why
would I pull the gun man I ain't trying
to be
another man come on man I don't have to
say it I don't have to say it man Hayes
again tells the officer he has children
at home saying he's fighting for his
life and that he did nothing wrong I'm
fighting for my life man I got four
babies at the house man what they what
happened and they would have come on man
I understand For Nothing
though up today I'm paying on it like I
got a good job I work security I work
security like I'm I'm I'm trying to be
one of y'all but like no moment this how
yall do this how yall do me work to be
bro I didn't do anything my name man
besides speeding tickets man right I
understand and like what I said I do
apologize like if you feel like they
they roughed you up or whatever I do
apologize but anytime that there's a gun
involved and like traffic stoping like
hey
give us a second we're going to have
these D check you
out give me a second so what about the
gun sir when y ran the what it say when
I ran it and you saw me run it it came
back clear it's not stolen none of that
right so damn can I like they don't even
know my aune they they in big trouble
man they in big trouble they don't even
know I look like this but I got family
that's behind me man son I got family
that's behind me I'm a smart I'm I'm
fuck smarted I'm an intelligent black
man man come on I just look like this
man looks have nothing to do I'm just
saying how they R me up how they hun me
like this like I'm some I didn't come at
them disrespectful I like hey you yeah
cuz we pulled up and everybody was
fighting and we just wanted to just just
end right exactly it was because of them
I didn't say anything man I I was
complying if they had their radio on I
was complying man if they had the camera
on I was compling like come on man like
this it should even have to be out this
man I got you are you the te or like
what what are you do me yeah so I'm part
of this team so this is all my team like
all these dudes are my teammates come on
man you got to you need a better team
man you need a better team and that's
why me I rather talk to everybody good
right wrong and different talk to I'll
talk to everybody at least you trying to
you they didn't even try to hear me man
okay no I'm just putting my hand up here
huh I'm just putting my hand up here
okay like so they'll check you out and
like what I said let me figure out
what's going on here and I and I'll talk
to you okay all right give me a second
meanwhile more officers search Hay's
car
um got another
magazine soon a Dallas Police Sergeant
arrives on the scene the original two
officers who pulled Haze over explain
what happened we were sitting at the
church and we're just going to start
doing traffic she's running flates M run
that Hyundai so she runs it and she was
like oh let's look at the registered
owner or whatever so she does she goes
to AIS and that's a cross reference and
it pops up red so she's like uh
okay she kind of looks at it but by that
time we had already lost them we had
already gone into like the Family Dollar
parking lot or whatever the Family
Dollar parking lot so
then as she's
searching she finds out that the name
that she put on there whatever was on
AIS had continuous Family Violence you
know warant so
then we get behind him up here cuz we
see we see the car moving on Illinois so
we catch up to it and we get up here to
uh Southern Oaks and he fails to Signal
within 100 ft from the stop sign here
Southern Oaks and Overton and as soon as
he came up here you know we obviously
pulled him over so he got the reason for
contact yeah so I pulled up to the car
and I'm like hey man
look you know you have pulled over for
this this and this and he was like well
that's not fair cuz you were watching me
from the other side I was like yeah we
were on the other side of the light but
you were crossing so obviously you know
what I mean yeah so then I was just like
you have your ID with you and so he
gives it to me and obvious I hand it
over to her and she was like Sylvester
Hayes like that's the name that was
under warrant but so you got a good
warrant well there's I guess a lot of he
does have tickets he does have the
tickets so when I'm like hey bro so in
order for us
to in order for us to be able to like
fully investigate like cuz he was
already acting weird so I'm like hey bro
like he was already giving him trouble
like I'm like can can you just step out
of the car for let's go to the back of
the car and at that point he was like
for what for what and I'm like bro come
on man and so that's whenever regie
pulled up and we tried to get him out of
the car and the fight was on okay and
then I was like bro come so you got uh
jail traffic resist and arrest right
yeah we have filed to sign ft and then
he has tickets he had a gun in his
pocket cuz he kept going like this why
he was so crazy okay he had had a pistol
in his in his freaking uh pocket so and
at that point whenever we were trying to
get him out of the car Whitman was on
the other side he was a gun gun gun
right Pocket Gun yeah so is he a felon
uh he has not been convicted or no felon
no
felon we we have
ucw resist resistant okay resistant
because well that I don't know if we
were're going to be able to put the
resistant because you can't resist the
you can get him out of the car but I
mean if the fight is
on hold on so so res so who was on the
driver's side I was so he was listening
to your commands at the time right no he
was not as soon as I yeah I had to open
the door when I was like hey come on
come on let's St wh Miss saw the gun sa
at this point right he saw he saw the
gun while we were trying to get him out
of the car so you got you know what I'm
saying yeah okay so when he was sitting
down and we like me Reggie and who was
who else next to were trying to pull him
out of the car that's whenever women was
trying to push him out he was a gun gun
gun right Pocket Gun right pocket okay
and
so but based on your investigation you
have probable CS to stop him because you
got y'all looked at his name in his
picture earlier and could identify uh we
couldn't see in the car we we have the
traffic violations have the traffic
violation ra for contact yeah so I
wasn't going to be like oh it's an
investigator stop and and it turns into
like no we were going to get so when the
pistol come back clean sto uh it was
clean clean okay
um double check with a jail Sergeant on
a ucw charge okay all right um just to
make sure cuz you know we got new laws
now yeah right so if he's not a feling
but not convicted of one that's
different any drugs in the car I don't
know I don't think so okay they just
y'all just searched the car yeah they I
don't they haven't said anything okay
let's find and then what was his injury
nothing but if he resisted he resisted
you know what I'm saying so we got him
on that right yeah so so we good so yeah
so just uh find out just before the
recording ends the officer mentions
confusion with the other Sylvester Hayes
the Lester ended up being like the third
or something like that but as soon as I
saw the Lester Hayes I was like okay
let's get him out
well according to court documents Hayes
lost his job as a security guard and his
home after the arrest he now alleges his
fourth and 14 Amendment rights were
violated during his arrest the lawsuit
alleges he was racially profiled leading
to his arrest the lawsuit points to two
counts of excessive force and one count
of unlawful arrest Hayes is now seeking
a jury trial punitive damages and
attorneys fees reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie